now for the Iranian reaction into
president Trump's action Iran's
president Hassan rouhani said that Iran
will remain inside the deal along with
the EU Russia and China despite
president Trump's desertification
Elizabeth Palmer is in Tehran and she's
just spoken with the Foreign Minister
Mohammad Javad Zarif who negotiated the
deal on behalf of Iran it was good
morning good morning yes
foreign minister Zarif spent two years
working very hard to bring this deal to
fruition but he wouldn't admit to being
disappointed this morning at least on
camera he's still portraying it as a
triumph of diplomacy because as you
mentioned the five other countries who
signed our standing in solidarity with
Iran as far as they concerned the deal
is just going to go ahead he he did tell
me that he felt that the net effect of
president Trump's move to decertify is
going to be to undermine us credibility
generally internationally nobody else
would trust any US administration to
engage in any long-term negotiation
because the length of any commitment the
duration of any commitment from now on
with any US administration would be the
reminder of the term of that president
now I asked him about some of the other
potential fallout for example Boeing's
ambition the great aircraft maker to
sail Iran 80 new planes a deal worth
billions would it go ahead I asked he
said yes Iran has no bone to pick with
American business as far as Iran is
concerned that's just fine and then I
said did president Trump's aggressive
tone and his words put the kibosh on
Iran's desire to open some kind of
better relations with the United States
and this is what he said I believe the
Trump administration is closing its eyes
on the realities of our region we
believe it would be important for the
United States for the trumpet ministry
to exercise a reset and it's cognitive
disorder with regard to our reach listen
to what degree did dr. Zarif and the
Iranian government know beforehand what
President Trump was going to say about
desertification I asked him where he
watched the speech and he watched it
live in the same building as the Iranian
president he said there were no
surprises in it he did not get a phone
call from for example the US Secretary
of State for a heads up nor from any
other official in the administration
which gives you an idea of how bad and
and and chilly diplomatic relations are
but he did say there were no surprises
because the European allies had been
funneling information about what was
coming to him all week I see indeed
Elizabeth Palmer and Tehran thanks Liz